SURFER:
Nazaré is absolutely firing.
There's 30,000 people
on the cliff.
There's more hype,
there's more ego,
there's more fame.
And that all leads up
to one breaking point.
♪ (TENSE PIANO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
CJ MACIAS:
Garrett has this deep drive.
There's something about
the way he'll believe in you.
I love seeing people
accomplishing their goals,
their dreams,
doing what they love.
For me, surfing is a religion.
It's a mix of pure adrenalin,
fear, and happiness.
JUSTINE DUPONT:
I do it because I love it.
If I don't have a smile
on my face,
it's not worth it.
I've always seen her
like a superhero.
Nothing can happen to her.
SURFER 2:
This is what I want to do
for the rest of my life.
Every season, you wanna perform,
you wanna do your best.
It'll make your career
or break it.
DUPONT: You need to push
yourself if you want to succeed.
But sometimes,
I feel like it's too much.
SURFER 3: I want to prove
that I'm not a kid anymore.
MACIAS: The fear,
the love, the stress.
Why do I need such
an extreme circumstance...
in order to feel alive?
Oh, my God.
I don't see him anywhere!
GARRETT MCNAMARA:
I've never seen Nicole
so afraid.
She needed me
to be there for her.
KAI LENNY: The biggest enemy
that you have to overcome
is your own mind.
When you start
doubting yourself,
you might not come home at all.
SPEAKER: People don't realize
we put everything on the line.
We know that sometimes
we only get one shot.